j'accueille bruno gaccio
c'est un vrai public de télévision on
connaît sovar d'abord un c'est un vrai
public de télévision très très bien
dresser wayne les deux c'est normal en
ce moment tout le monde vous soutient
tout le monde vous admire tout le monde
en parle et ben tiens we know vous êtes
l'auteur en chef des guignols on va pas
dire en chef on va dire le plus vieux le
plus ancien il ya pas de chef et vous
avez pris cette semaine la tête de la
mutinerie qui secoue canal+ alors on va
pas dire mutinerie on va pas dire j'ai
pris la tête on va commencer par
rectifier ouais y'a pas de mutinerie
donc ça va pas utoya pas de mutinerie
facilement vers une mutinerie mais si
oui oui ah oui d'accord mais une
mutinerie mais s'il avait fait une
mutinerie lui je sais pas ce qu'il est
en train de faire et personne ne
comprend ce qu'il est en train de faire
c'est bien ça le problème mais nous il
n'y a pas de mutinerie on va pas prendre
l'antenne en est on est des gens
responsables quand même on sait qu'on
fait de la télévision n'est pas des fous
par contre on n'est pas d'accord il ya
plein de sujets sur lesquels on n'est
pas tout à fait d'accord et notamment le
remplacement de pierre lescure on n'est
pas d'accord du tout on est plein à dire
et on voudrait bien garder le patron et
le patron c'est pierre lescure et c'est
quelque chose qui ne s'est jamais vu
encore ça n'existe pas à déployer qui se
battent pour leur patron c'est vrai que
c'est pour leur patron ils se battent
pour le garder celui là précisément
parce que c'est celui là le bon on n'est
pas des débiles mentaux on sait que
c'est celui là le bon par contre celui
qui tout au dessus l'actionnaire qui
fait n'importe quoi celui là si on
pouvait le pousser un peu ça serait pas
mal parce que c'est lui qui met la merde
pour l'instant il ya que lui qui met la
merde magnéto serge
je
oui
[Musique]
ça s'est passé comment cet âge et là
vous avez appris ça comment à quelle
heure mardi et comment tout le monde
s'est retrouvé dans le grand studio de
canal le film des événements voilà c'est
on était en train nous travailler donc
aux guignols on travaille généralement
avec la télévision généralement avec i
télévision parce que c'est de l'info en
boucle et on voit passer un bandeau
messi a décidé de débarquer pierre
lescure il sera débarqué tout ça donc on
sort du bureau comme tout le monde doit
avoir les jantes est sur c'est quoi
imachin banque en dix minutes on dit il
ya un problème il faut changer le jt des
guignols de ce soir et je sais pas de
fil en aiguille donc il ya plein de gens
qui descendent tout le monde sur des
couloirs c'est pas possible ça peut pas
exister comme ça on descend sur les
plateaux il ya les les syndicats parce
que ça sert quand même quelque chose
dans ces cas là qui coordonne s'est vite
ils disent pas pour niva et puis on se
retrouve tous sur un plateau et puis là
il ya n'importe quoi qui fusent comme
n'importe comment tout âge et quand vous
en avez peut-être fait je sais pas moi
sans suite ben ouais mais ne s'est pas
tu as fait 68 là du coup et donc il ya
plein d'idées qui fusent des idées à la
con genre envoyer les décodeurs ce qu'il
faut surtout pas faire c'est vrai que
les dés le les abonnements des gens leur
argent leur engagement à eux c'est notre
liberté à nous donc c'est nous aide pas
du tout de dire on s'en va ça c'est pas
bien il ya qu'est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
on va prendre l'antenne on va faire des
va prendre l'antenne pour nous donc on
s'imagine très bien avec des
syndicalistes bord alors que je n'ai pas
d'accord ambert non je ne sais pas
d'accord un footing et alors et ben moi
non plus et alors
voilà donc on va faire chier tout le
monde et donc on s'est dit le meilleur
moyen parce qu'on s'est vus avec faire
vous dirai évidemment tout les gens sont
d'accord pour faire ça je n'exprimerai
dans plusieurs personnes on s'est dit on
va faire l'antenne comme d'habitude et
plein de gens venaient nous voir le
mardi soir plein de gens des mecs qui
avaient été virés dans un plan social de
217 personnes quand même il y en avait
20 25 qui étaient là qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire pour aider ben je sais pas
sur ton téléphone apple des copains et
des mecs qu'on avait viré pas qu'on
avait viré c'est pas moi mais que qui
avait été viré parce que comme y avait
plus nulle part ailleurs il y avait
moins de travail donc on avait écarté
des gens les gens qui tu es parti qui
revenaient dimanche à un truc de ouf ça
c'est assez rare des mecs qui sont
licenciés qui reviennent alors c'est pas
le bonheur absolu il ya des gens qui
sont pas d'accord avec ça mais il ya une
immense majorité de gens qui disent et
on le garde lescure et on vient mais si
l'idée c'est ça c'est aussi comme ça
alors imaginez wano gaccio le 24 avril
il ya un conseil d'administration de
vivendi universal
mais s'y est mis en minorité par ses
actionnaires et on peut imaginer un
scénario à la chavez président du
venezuela qui revenue deux jours après
est ce qu'on veut si ça va faire plaisir
à lescure raisin suis pas sûr est ce
qu'on peut imaginer que lescure reste
président moi je l'espère de tout mon
coeur je pense pas lui il est légaliste
il est obligé ya des procédures à
respecter je crois qu'il a envie de le
respecter il est pas il veut pas faire
fort chabrol ça n'intéresse pas il veut
pas faire de la résistance il veut juste
lui un truc c'est que canal+ soit pas
démantelée et
il veut que ce qu'on a mis 17 ans à
construire soit pas rayer d'un coup de
plume d'un coût de 2 bluffs de
je-ne-sais-quoi de jean-marie mais si on
ne sait pas pourquoi il fait ça il ya
une espèce d'incohérences à notre esprit
dans ce qu'il est en train de faire
pourquoi il fait ça il faut sauver
canal+ on est tous d'accord imaginons
des imaginons des trucs fous on a
imaginé tout on a dit imaginons qu'il
appelle un tipi ultra compétent ou un
type de télévision dont je ne sais pas
j'ai pas de noms qui viennent et je
voudrais pas vexer les autres en même
temps le mec arrive il dit voilà je suis
le sauveur parce que ça parce que ça
parce que ça et parce que le pognon on
dit bon d'accord le seul truc qui nous
amène ses coutures couture c'est on lui
en veux pas je ne connais pas
personnellement je ne sais rien de lui
je peux lui faire des procès d'intention
simplement dans le symbole pour une
chaîne comme canal + faire venir le
numéro 3 de tf1 c'est une erreur
monumentale pour notre pour notre
psychologie à nous c'est un peu une
faute de goût voulait dire oui c'est pas
la première de messier j'ai vu ses
chaussettes j'ai dû sa bagnole j'aimais
ses chemises c'est pas la première
mais oui il ya faute de goût bien faute
de goût et où il ya méconnaissance
totale de ce qu'est canal+ on n'est pas
une chaîne on s'est connu une chaîne
commerciale on n'est pas idiot on se
connaît pas une chaîne de
révolutionnaire on sait simplement qu'on
fait le pendant à certaines choses il ya
le service public cette émission dont on
pense tous qu'elle est plutôt bien qui
fait son boulot c'est une certaine
partie du travail tf1 qui couvre la plus
large partie du public le plus large
avec de la télé qu'on n'a pas forcément
envie de faire mais que des gens
regardent pas
nous on propose autre chose c'est autre
chose est réellement en danger parce que
couture il va pas de donner envie il va
pas faire bander 2000 personnes qui
bossent à canal ils sont tous comme ça
les mecs ont regardé couture et font un
battant c'est un mec de télé peut-être
qu'il a des idées s'ils avaient des
idées à 50 piges et les aurait fait je
ne sais pas je sais pas si l'on est fait
pour ça lui il est pas et n'est pas
parfait vous mettez pas là pour le coup
pour l'exception culturelle mais pour la
diversité culturelle d'une certaine
façon on se bat pour une idée qu'on a de
la télévision c'était que c'est que ça
canal c'est une certaine idée c'est un
avis sur les choses c'est une façon de
faire date et l'heure des fois on se
plante gravement ont fait des grosses
bouses je peux pas dire que j'étais
ravie de même avec toute l'amitié que je
leur porte de regarder wendel gomme et
jean et du genre qui faisait une
émission qui étaient ils sont tous hyper
sympa mais elle n'était pas bandant tu
as regardé on le sait on l'a vu mais on
est comme ça nous on n'arrive pas à
arrêter les choses en disant bon allez à
peut-être plus tard non on dit on on
tergiverse on a perdu du temps on a
perdu de l'argent oui c'est des erreurs
c'est vrai c'est des conneries on aurait
pu dû être méchant mais on n'a pas fait
et puis on a pris du retard bon ben
voila et maintenant que ça repart parce
qu'il ya une vraie dynamique un vrai
truc est en train de passer ce moment
vous devez faire de l'audience ça parce
que c'est vachement
réponse justement il ya du monde c'est
horrible
dites-moi réseau les bonnes émissions
est ce que finalement tout ça n'était
quand même pas prévisible depuis la
fusion ah oui non mais parce que
l'esprit et l'âme accepté d'avaler pas
mal de coups la vendra non
moi je pense et je vais peut-être me
fais engueuler par lescure ouais je
pense qu'il s'est bien fait [ __ ] parce
que moi messier même moi je les crues
parce qu'il est venu un jour avec un
employé de laquelle larmes aux yeux et
[ __ ] mais à ce moment-là ce jour dans
cette réunion je les dis arrêtez de nous
dire vous aimez vous aimez pas rouler
vous une peine et qu'on en finisse et on
va passer au travail même nom et c'était
assez d'accord avec ça bon ben on est
passé au travail alors il nous a dit il
ya un mois je donne deux ans aux
dirigeants pour redresser la barre un
mois après ils nous virent bon que
jean-marie ses 24 mois en quelques mois
fin et on va pas confier l'avenir de la
chaîne un mec qui sait pas qu'on fiche
de 24 c'est pas content et j'ai quand
même
est ce que est ce que pierre lescure
n'aurais pas dû partir avant ben ça
c'est là qu'un endroit il ya qu un
moment où il aurait pu partir et
peut-être dû partir ça je répondrais
jama sa place c'est quand rousselet
partie ouais on se perd en partant avait
dit ce qui pouvait se passer puisque
trois actionnaires se regroupant vous
pouvez diriger la chaîne c'est une loi
qui a été fait par carignon qui a fait
quand même quatre en taule derrière
c'est pour dire le bonhomme et qui était
initiée par balladur bon il s'est
retrouvé dans cette configuration
rousselet a dit cette configuration moi
je ne la supporte pas je m'en vais
pierre aurait dû dire je fais pareil
même ça c'était se draper se jeter le
truc sur l'épaule et de dire je pars
fier et de pourrir le boulot et on avait
dit à pire tu tiendras pas un an ça fait
8 20 m way légende est née huit ans
c'est déjà ça de pris finalement vous
découvrez le capitalisme non je savais
comment ça marche et avant mais je me
doute bien mais là sur le coup j'ai un
exemple précis et nous on essaie on
savait que ça pouvait arriver
la manière est quand même extrêmement
brutale oui la manière et on sait que
c'est jamais classe de virer des gens
mais là c'est pas classe du tout ccc
dans son dos c'est ces dix minutes après
avec coutures à côté lui est basse et
l'huile diva téléphone à pire tu veux
non tu veux pas bon je trouve quelqu'un
d'autre ça c'est quand même si un peu
c'est un peu gros c'est méchant si
lescure 120 tout le monde s'en va
c'est une guerre c'est une question en
suspens comme on le
sait ce qu'on est en train de discuter
c'est ce qu'il ya des gens qui disent je
me casse ya des gens qui disent jaurès
moi je suis pour rester les guignols en
tout cas restaurant moi je resterai je
veux pas faire fort chabrol non plus un
mais les guignols vous resterez pour
parler de couture a peut-être marron
noir y aura sa marionnette 1
1 mais si on lit cet après-midi aimé
qu'ils gardent couture pour tes
chaussettes ouais
voilà les guignols resteront il faudra
qu'ils nous dire ah ouais bah oui moi ça
fait des années que je dis je pars en
vacances à chaque fois une tombe un truc
sur la tête c'est vrai à une année tout
le monde nous tape dessus dont on est
obligé de rester si tu partes possible
mais après tu dis je prends des vacances
on change les auteurs et puis cette
année je dis bon à la fin de l'année les
mecs si vous travaillez bien c'est très
bien en ce moment les guignols la merci
non mais c'est vrai mais je suis pas le
seul à lire l'audience le dit non je
crois que si on se dit alors en ce
moment non oui c'est au tour de 13-14
les jours 18 plutôt le dimanche ça veut
rien dire pour vous mais pour nous c'est
ça veut dire beaucoup
pour moi
et c'est pas pour me vanter on est bien
reçue chez toi
est ce que par rapport aux gens de
moulinex vous sentez pas un peu quand
même et je vais pas dire connexes qu'on
gagne super bien notre vie nous si on
nous vire on peut survivre après
derrière on n'est pas ça on va pas jouer
le disais à billy ce n'est pas comme ça
en même temps à canal+ si ça se passe
mal s'il ya un démantèlement de la
chaîne si canal + 2 devient
visiblement c'est ce qu'ils ont envie de
faire messier qu'un tuyau pour diffuser
du foot et du cinéma et que le reste est
morcelé que la distribution se passe
ailleurs et que le reste est morcelé en
chaînes thématiques avec une fusion avec
le bouquet concurrents parce que ça
coûte cher pour les deux si ça ça se
passe c'est canal+ c'est un tuyau vide
qui va acheter qui va donner 180 balle
tous les mois pour un tuyau
commercialement c'est idiot tu nous fais
messier parce que non mais je peux lui
donner des leçons de capitaine non mais
on sait ce que c'est que l'intérieur de
canal plus jean c'est pourquoi
quel est le sentiment il ya une émotion
terrible il ya aussi une volonté
terrible c'est pas que des gens qui font
or on nous vire nous vient lescure non
lescure est le meilleur pour faire ce
que tu as à faire ou alors couture se
pointe avec un gros chèque est dit mais
s'il nous dit vous prenez couture vous
prenez chèque et vous recommencez à
travailler que les moyens mais si nous
coupe les moyens que nous mais couture
comment on va y arriver parce qu'on n'y
est pas arrivé que la meilleure du monde
c'est d'exclure ou hendaye arrivée
couture c'est pas vrai ce qu'il veut
faire cette démantelé c'est une erreur
de économique ouais
c'est ce que je crois
si vous devriez dire quelque chose à
face caméra comme ça jean marie messier
là maintenant vous lui diriez quoi tu es
dans la musique tu fais pas de musique
c'est dans la tête dans la télé tu sais
pas faire de télé tu es dans le cinéma
tu sais pas faire de cinéma et on vient
de s'apercevoir que c'est même pas faire
de la finance il ya un moment il faut
laisser faire les gens qui savent et
j'ai l'impression que là tu sais plus
jean marie
les corrections de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu